all right we have an anonymous Insider
now from Silicon Valley Bank and we
appreciate you calling us we're going to
keep your identity secret because I
think to my understanding you still may
be working there what kind of place was
it like to work it was a very you know
inclusive like work environment you know
it was it's a very hard place to get
fired from you know what I mean well
um that's gonna change they definitely
make you feel it's like you know
diversity and inclusion and all that
kind of stuff well well that's lovely
but that that clearly didn't stop the
nightmarish collapse and and right now
it's in the custody of the feds they're
running the bank and they they went to
look for a buyer and they couldn't find
one yeah I you know there were a bunch
of names loaded out like um the Saudi
Arabian Sovereign funder they love
diversity and inclusion the Saudi
Arabian Sovereign fund that's what I've
heard yeah that's really I'm sure they
got really excited when they go hey we
have a awoke failing Bank of non-binary
people